So, I will return back to my code. And here, I will attempt to make
an instance of class Movie, in much the same way we did for class Turtle. I
will start by creating a new Python file. I will then Save this file, in the
same folder as my previous Python file. And
I will call this new file entertainment_center.py. So,
here are my two Python files that I have created
thus far. Here's the first one, where I began to
define the class Movie. It was called media.py. And here
is is the new file called entertainment_center.py. Now, here in
this new file, I will say, import media. Now notice
that this is my media file, which is where I
was beginning to define my Movie class and therefore, with
this line of code, I am telling my program, hey here,
I want to use the contents of my previous Python file. Then I will go on to
say toy_story is equal to media.Movie. So, you may
notice here that media is name of my previous
Python file and Movie is the name of
the class that's defined inside that file. One quick
side note here is that I did not have to create a new file. In fact, I could
have written this entire piece of code right here
in my previous file. But it is good practice to
keep the class definition in one file and to call
your class, or to use your class from another file.
Okay, let's continue. So, there is one thing I
want to highlight here. Which is that this line of
code is pretty similar to how we created the turtle
brad. In both cases, I am saying, some module or
file name dot a class name. Now, the next
thing we have to do is figure out exactly what
happens when we run this line of code. One way
to do that is to remember what happened behind the
scenes. When we created the turtle brad. So, let's
investigate that together. Do you remember what happens when we
run the following line of code? Here are some answer
choices. A function named init is called; it initializes or
creates space in memory for the new instance brad. Or, a
function named D-E-L, or del it's called, it deletes the instance brad.
A function named cmp, or compare is called. It compares the instance
brad to angie, or, I don't know. Tell us what you think.